今日はこう見えて実はカレーライスが一番好き
高齢者庁でスプーンで皆さん無印良品にいろんなものが売ってるんですけどもうなんか
その中で猛烈にし良品のれ続くと彼がめちゃくちゃ美味しいみたいなのあるじゃない
ですか食べたことないけどけどならそうらしいんですよ
買ってきたんですけどなんかめちゃくちゃ種類があってちょっとずれて出します
あって待ってます
おこや貼っていいでしょうか例のこだわりが&超えとるかいて月と落ちきれないんです
けども近くの二ズルし病気に行くだけで31週でやりました
すごいなぁ無印良品のコンセプトがわからんですよ数が彼31処理を冠すよねなんか
矛盾しのかね美味しいって聞くんですよねちょっと紹介していきましょうます様欧風
ビーフカレーアーネルば髪があるから来ない国産玉ねぎと豚肉のカレー7 j 0バー
のクリーミーチキンカレービーフカレー厚切りベーコンのスープカレーから来ない国産
りんごと野菜カレーブラウンマーサーから来ない高齢層のキーマカレー
ローラー台で2月リーグの桜後に金4番リスの森からチキンの森金ちょっと止まったの
かねぇ
場所実機フレームパッチって下山優しいスープカレーバーマットピューター蛇口権
フリー私キー6ザラキーマから来てく日から多少とか車スズキパレット切り崩しかね
ポトポト bigbang って本当にマーチンとコロコロ野菜とスープがねぇ
ほほうこれすごい措置とみてくださいいやいやすごい横の両
全部カレーですからね本当にもう何か甘いのか辛いのから何でもあるんですけども
チキンからですねあんな女のチキンカレーだと辛くないっていうのがあってですね
全部美味しそうです全部全部食べたい
全種類食べたいでも全部食べれないっても全種類食べたい
でも全部冷たいでも全部種類食べたいでも食べれないって思っやるっていう護符
混ぜますはい今言った通りで全部混ぜます安心して下さいそれで6ずれ書のこれ全部
うまいんだよこれ道一つ外れがないんで得る上でとても愛してむず薄いのはメートルと
かで全部混ぜて食ったらどんなをして金ができるのが結構キャッチで世界で美味しい
可能性あると思います早速作っていいでしょ
まずが
受洗バーガーファーやなにを隠そう私レトルトカレーじゃまともに作ったことないから
な
大湯前ってあるでしょうねこれねしてさぁづアツとりあえず熱してお湯の中にどんどん
これ入れて温めればいいということですよね
このまま須藤車を呼んな感じで結構7分加熱してくださいバカッター
これなら僕にもできそうだよずっと待ちます
もうこれ沸騰してるってことでよくねもうあがプツプツでてれて良いと思いますれて
いきましょう
音でいうかなぷっちょ
うわっ
全部使ってるんで大丈夫だと思いますそれで水がつければいいんでしょ
a-ha つい
差分デビュー戦できます
公約のポイントつからねこうずちょっと言いましょうね
[音楽]
全部折っちゃった場合というでこのな女の中にあったまったりというカレーをどんどん
入れていきました
思っ
をは甘さと
はいとよくで全部位で終わりましたまま色はまあまあいるはまぁそんなもんです誰か
混ぜたらから変わると思うんだよね
混ぜてみます
ぷっ
まあ完璧に渡った均等の色になりました
というわけでこちらから無印の最強カレーデー
見た感じはただの華麗なんですよね
ああああああ
うわーん何億種類のスパイスが入ってるかわかりませんから
果たして30種類のメダルと彼がマッサージどんな味がするのでしょうか
いきます
待ってなければ入れすぎたやはりカレーの海になっちゃったご飯が見えなくなっちゃい
ました
まあでもそれのおいしいでしょでは早速いただきたいと思います
大嫌いこれまずメっつってないと思うんだよな
[音楽]
黄疸が切れる前にまってこれ皆さんは勝ってると思ってもリアクションをとれないと
いうことは本当に教えてことですよこれ
[音楽]
ちょっと待ってちょっともうちょっと食べさせてくださいうん甘いです
中根思ったより結構鋼の華麗な感じがします
なぜば本当にちょっとあの表月ぐらいですね色んな味が混ざって歯磨いてそのマイルド
なクリーミーたもの後日
補修シックと野菜も入っており猛暑すぎ非の打ち所がないんじゃないかという気がして
おりますこれやばい
一周年2杯食べちゃったそしてハッカー
作用がやばいですねっちゃ世界てます動いもヴァイスも引いてて辛くででもあなた回っ
てクリーミーさも残しつつ
処遇頭が止まらなくなってしまう史上最強のカレーでしたいやー素晴らしかったです
ねー
[拍手]
31にマイカー
みんなん
me
car